so everybody is talking about how
President Trump was booed by Nationals
fans last night they also shouted lock
him up and if you haven't seen it yet
here's the here's the clip of that
[Applause]
so listen some people are upset by by
that but my point is you can't really
blame them can you I mean Trump did just
kill a scholar after all and I'll steer
one at that it's one thing to go around
killing scholars but to kill and I'll
steer scholar of all things well you
just can't do that so it's hard to blame
them we'll talk about al Baghdadi's
death and especially how the media
reacted to it including the Washington
Post now infamous characterization as I
just alluded to of the terrorist leader
as an austere religious scholar we've
also got to talk about Kanye West of
course and his new gospel album also him
him coming out as pro-life which i think
is the is the more significant
revelation over the last week
about Kanye West and Katy Hill resigned
we've been following this story for the
last week or two talk about that as well
but Katy Hill has resigned the
congresswoman who engaged in absurdly
unethical and probably illegal behavior
she resigned but guess who is the victim
you're never gonna guess who's really
the victim in this story we'll talk
about all that and more but first a word
from brick house have you ever wondered
why so many Americans are sick unhealthy
overweight between the foods the food
supply and our lethargic sedentary
lifestyle Americans are in the worst
shape ever what do you expect when we
sit around all day on our beanbag chairs
you know eating Twinkies which I've
never had a Twinkie in my life to be
honest with you but I hear that they're
not very healthy but when you do that
you're gonna end up fat and unhealthy
and that's why the team of on staff
physicians at brickHouse nutrition
created field of greens field of greens
is an easy way for you to add fruits and
vegetables to your daily routine without
spending hours in the produce section
hiring a home chef or taking cheap
supplements as I've said before with
produce you know you want to make sure
that especially you have kids and
everything you're the people in the
house are eating produce but it's really
expensive and anyone who knows has ever
been to a grocery store you know how
expensive it is field of greens solves
that problem it's made with real USDA
organic fruits and vegetables all
helps boost your immunity using
antioxidants and assist digestive health
of prebiotics and probiotics it's like
having a doctrine intro and a
nutritionist right there in your kitchen
waiting for you one scoop delivers a
full serving of fruits and vegetables
just drop drop it in a cup of water stir
it up and you're done it's as easy as
that bottom line this is real food it's
not extracts you will look and feel
better go to brick house walsh dot-com
get 15% off your first order just for
trying it out with promo code Walsh
that's brick house walsh dot-com promo
code walsh alright so a Bakar abu bakar
al-baghdadi and make sure we pronounce
his name right at a respect for the dead
Isis leader brutal savage sadistic mass
murdering rapist was killed this weekend
as you've heard blew himself up like a
coward as American forces were closing
in the world is a much better place
without him and we can be quite sure on
top of that that the virgin's he was
expecting to wake up to after he blew
himself to smithereens well we could be
sure that he probably was was
disappointed when he when he awoke there
were no virgins well we'll just say that
this is a great win for the good guys
for the world politically for for Donald
Trump but that factor Donald Trump
combined with the fact that Baghdadi was
Muslim seemed to cause real problems for
the media it just it kind of sent them
it they got all discombobulated based on
those two factors you'd think this story
is pretty straightforward pretty simple
scumbag terrorist dies we celebrate
that's how it should be but the media
well for the media it's never that
simple especially when it comes to
Donald Trump they can't give Trump
credit for anything ever and also they
can never put identity politics to the
side which is why they spent the last 48
hours in it would seem almost morning
they've almost been mourning the death
of a man who would lock people in
ages and set them on fire a man who
raped more women than Genghis Khan
they've they have almost been it would
seem upset that he died now let's go to
the most infamous example and I've seen
this by now but we've really got to
break this thing down because it is
incredible the Washington Post Baghdadi
dies and immediately the post puts up an
obituary with this headline this was her
first headline it said Abu Bakr al
Baghdadi is la McStay --ts terrorist in
chief dies at 48 now this with the way
that's phrase dies with the passive
phrasing it makes it seem like he died
peacefully in his sleep of a heart
attack or a you know died of pancreatic
cancer or something
it doesn't quite let on to the fact that
American forces effectively killed him
by forcing him to blow himself up but
other than that the headlines find
terrorists and chief sure that's a fine
description but then comes the headline
change and they change it to a headline
that will live forever in infamy
Abu Bakar al-baghdadi austere religious
scholar at the helm of the love of
Islamic state dies at 48 austere
religious scholar a headline that as
many have people have been it kind of
makes you wonder how they eulogized
other famous murderers like Timothy
McVeigh noted political activist dies at
33 or John Wayne Gacy boisterous party
clown and children's entertainer dies at
52 Ted Bundy famous ladies man dies at
42 Adolf Hitler prominent painter and
environmentalist dies at 56 and so on
the really amazing thing about this is
that Washington Post it's it's the fact
that they changed the headline okay so
there had to be a real thought process
that went into this there was a
discussion there had to be a discussion
that involved
whereas people there had to have been an
actual audible conversation among
multiple people at this supposedly
respected news organization and that
conversation had to begin with someone
saying something like hey guys this
headline about the serial raping
terrorist is a little harsh why don't we
try to highlight his positive sides a
little bit more or the conversation
could have started with something more
like hey guys this headline might make
people think that Donald Trump did
something good how can we make it seem
like less of a victory for him
however the conversation started this is
this is what you ended up with and the
other amazing thing is that apparently
you would assume they didn't think they
would get any backlash for it they were
blindsided by the backlash which is why
they ended up changing the headline a
second time it took them three tries to
get to it to get to a headline about
something about a very simple story one
of the worst people in the world is dead
real simple it took them three tries to
get to the right headline but the fact
that I again multiple people people
looked at the headline nodded their
heads and said yep perfect nobody will
have any issue with this this is great
which just goes to show why the media
embarrasses itself so often and why it
is so hated because these people who
work in the media really don't
understand how normal human beings work
and I think that's a problem if you're
in the media and your job is to
communicate your job is to communicate
with normal people and tell them what's
going on in the world so if you don't
understand how a normal brain works
that's going to be a very difficult
thing to do they thought that normal
humans would prefer for a terrorist
leader to be characterized as a
religious scholar and that is incredible
but and I haven't seen anyone really
point anyone else really point us out
the the the other funny thing here the
irony is that in an attempt to be to be
woke in an attempt to be tolerance due
to they're suffocating fear of being
Islamophobic they only ended up
insulting Islam as well because think
about it austere in this context means
strict or rigid or you know
uncompromising so someone you know in a
religious context if you say that
someone is austere what you're saying is
that they very strictly adhere to the
fundamentals of their religion so if you
call Baghdadi
in austere scholar of Islam what you're
saying obviously is that he is someone
who adheres very closely to and
understands very well the the
fundamentals of of the religion that's
what it means to be austere and
scholarly in this context so what is the
post implying are they implying that a
strict observance of Islam would lead to
Isis now I know they weren't trying to
imply that but they did that is what
they implied they forgot that as in the
media they forgot what they normally do
they they figure out what their normal
line is and this is what happens when
you are so you know when when when
you're so committed to always going to
certain talking points and not
necessarily communicating the truth
sometimes you get mixed up and you
forget what your talking point is
supposed to be because it can be hard to
remember right in fairness to them so
they forgot that their talking point is
usually that guys like Baghdadi guys in
Isis they don't understand their own
religion they don't know anything about
Islam they they aren't even really
Muslim at all that's usually their line
in the media they forgot about that and
this time they went with oh no he's a
scholar of Islam
this is this is just this is what
happens when when you try to be woke
this is what happens now it wasn't just
the Washington Post embarrassing itself
a lot of media folks were upset by well
specifically not just the what happened
but also the way that Trump described
the death of Baghdadi in his address to
the nation was very scandalizing for
some of the people in in Washington with
very weak stomachs who can't deal with
it so here's a clip of that address from
the president last night the United
States brought the world's number-one
terrorist leader to justice Abu Bakar al
Baghdadi is dead
he died after running into a dead-end
tunnel whimpering and crying and
screaming all the way Baghdadi's demise
demonstrates America's relentless
pursuit of terrorist leaders and our
commitment to the enduring and total
defeat of Isis and other terrorist
organizations our reach is very long he
will never again harm another innocent
man woman or child he died like a dog he
died like a coward the world is now a
much safer place god bless america
thank you Wow well that is that is
really upsetting isn't it
how could president Trump say such mean
things about that poor man dog coward
have some respect right this this is
outrageous nobody deserves to be spoken
of this way oh wait a second hold on
oh no no no yeah yeah oh he definitely
does deserve to be spoken of this way
people some people definitely do deserve
to be spoken up like that some people
are murderous scumbags who bring nothing
but death and misery and suffering and
oppression to the world and when they
die the appropriate and right thing is
to celebrate and laugh because they are
dead that is the appropriate thing to do
sometimes when people die the idea that
we should respect
everyone who dies of course is crazy yes
if they're not respectable when they
live with there's no reason why we have
to restart respecting them now and
there's no reason why we have to pretend
that there's anything solemn about their
death when there isn't so what Trump
says here is not only acceptable but
actually the only acceptable way to talk
about a piece of garbage when they are
finally thrown out as they deserve to be
yet the media had its feelings heard
again not just the media but the DC
elites as well and those were by the way
by the way those were the same people
booing Trump at the Nationals game so it
makes a lot of sense and the Nationals
their fans are 90% DC bureaucrats and
lobbyists and lawyers so if you're
getting booed by them that's that's I'd
be I would be very upset if you go out
onto the field at Nationals game and you
don't get booed by these people that's a
bad sign so the fact that Trump was
booed I think is is is a great side for
him and a great honor now here's an
example of someone who was upset day
Nichelle Smith a bureaucrat and
Georgetown fellow who lists her pronouns
in her Twitter bio just to give you an
idea this is what she said about what
what Trump said she said this gruesome
vivid and probably exaggerated
description of dogs chasing down
Baghdadi will endanger our personnel in
the region when bin Laden was killed we
were careful to be clear that we had
been that we had given him a proper
Muslim burial not because we gave a damn
about him but because it was important
for our relationships in the region and
safety of our military and diplomats
also it's how America rolls with honor
we don't delight in death like the
terrorists do this description is
horrifying should go without saying but
to be perfectly clear clear I'm
remarking on the presser not on the
actual operation the killing of Big
Daddy was unquestionably good and
necessary so she says she's glad the
terrorist was killed but the way that it
was described made her tummy hurt and
she's really worried and concerned about
that she's not the only one concerned
Michael Morell the former deputy
director of the CIA went on Fay
the nation to talk about how bothered
and concerned he is with the rhetoric
surrounding the death of this scumbag
terrorists
listen of this so late I'll let Sandy
answer the operational military question
but to me right this is a great day we
should be really thankful that Baghdady
is gone and clearly the intelligence
community community and the US military
did an amazing job and the president
made exactly the right decision the
president thank Gina hospitalist
educator and I think we'll learn more in
the days ahead about what the
intelligence was and and how we got it
and thank you for more people on
bothered me a little bit some of what
the president did in in in providing
detail about taking back to the United
States pieces of Baghdadi's body it
bothered me a little bit hearing the
president talk about that some of that
Syrian oil being ours right because
that's what inspires that's what
inspires some extremists you know the
the oil comments Margaret really
validate at least it sounds to people
like it validates 40 to 50 years of
conspiracy theories about what American
foreign policy is all about right and
it's not so a great great day but I
think the president could have handled
the press conference a little bit better
very bothered very very bothered I'm so
bothered by this poor guy of course this
idea from from the woman that I just
read or this guy this idea that we're
gonna obsess Isis even more because we
say mean things about their dead leader
she said it's gonna endanger personnel
in the region right because Isis Isis
they were big fans of Americans prior to
this they were they were they were
totally onboard with us but now that
we've said mean things about their dead
leader now they're gonna be you know a
little bit testy probably with American
personnel who know of course Isis they
already killed Americans they they
already you're not gonna change nothing
what do they think is gonna change now
they they've swore
that you know if they've they have
declared war on the West already and
then we killed their leader thank God so
I think those two factors already are
that's pretty much all they need I don't
see how rhetoric is going to add to
anything are they implying that there
are Isis militants who you know weren't
already really sold on on bringing down
the West and declaring jihad but now
that they've heard president Trump's
unseemly rhetoric they're saying you
know why actually yeah
death to the West I tend to doubt it
all right um let's go to a different
story here important update on a story
that we've been talking about Katie Hill
the congresswoman who had a nasty habit
of sleeping with her subordinates is
resigning from Congress and this is
pretty incredible actually because on
Monday last Monday we we talked about
this story and at the time the story was
part of the story anyway was that nobody
was talking about the story and the
media was showing no interest and it
looked like she was going to get away
with these Blake blatant ethical
violations look like she would get away
with it because the media wasn't paying
attention they just decided they were
going to ignore it which is one of the
reasons why it took Katie Hill several
days before she even came out and
acknowledged this this this story when
it was first published by red state who
did great journalism on this on this by
the way it was several days
she was very lackadaisical in her
response because she didn't need to get
on top of it the way that I would argue
a male politician in her situation would
have to but we much as we did with the
james-younger case last week we pressed
this we spoke out about it we forced the
media to take note and now she's leaving
and I know we talked about this on
Friday but it's worth reiterating that
if there is an important story that's
going on that the media is trying to
bury one of the great
about the internet and there are a lot
of terrible things about the internet
but one of the great things is that we
can use it to force the media to take
note of it we don't have to just sit
back and complain about why isn't anyone
talking about this story if it's an
important story we think people should
pay attention to we can bypass the media
so it's not even really I guess I should
stipulate it's it's not even so much
forcing the media to take note it's more
bypassing them and saying forget about
you we don't need you we're gonna tell
everybody about this and then when
everyone's talking about it anyway now
them now the media has to swing around
and say something about it because it's
way too conspicuous that they're
ignoring it so we can do that now and we
did it twice last week with two
different stories and and this is
something we should be doing a lot more
often so now she's leaving Congress
she's resigning but she's not leaving
apologetically she is because she's the
victim here
she and she wants us to know that she is
the victim let me read for you a little
bit of her statement that she published
about leaving let me see if I pull this
up here it says it is with a broken
heart today that I announced my
resignation from Congress this is the
hardest thing I've ever had to do but I
believe it is the best thing for my
constituents my community in our country
this is what needs to happen so the good
people who supported me will no longer
be subjected to the pain inflicted by my
abusive husband and the brutality of
hateful political operatives who seem to
happily provide a platform to a monster
who is driving a smear campaign built
around cyber exploitation having private
photos of I just love how already you
know it sounds like she's gearing up for
some kind of apology where she says oh
they're no longer to be subjective to
the pain inflicted by and then you think
maybe to be my poor choices but it's by
my husband
having private photos of personal
moments weaponized against me has been
an appalling invasion of my privacy it's
also illegal and we are currently
pursuing all of our available legal
options however I know that as long as I
am in Congress will Liv fearful of what
come next and how much it will hurt
that's a feeling I know all too well
it's the feeling I decided to leave when
I I decided to leave when I left my
marriage and one I will not tolerate
being forced upon others I can no longer
allow my community family friends staff
supporters and especially the children
who look up to me as a role model to
suffer this unprecedented brand of
cruelty think of the children think of
the children who are upset by the fact
that my own ethical actions have been
exposed oh now we're getting to an
apology it looks like for the mistakes
made along the way and the people who
have been hurt I am so sorry and I'm
learning I'm not a perfect person and
never pretended to be it's the one thing
that made my race so special I hope it
showed others that they do belong that
their voice does matter and that they do
have a place in this country that is
something I believe with all my heart I
hope it show the other polyamorous
perverts who enjoy having sex with their
tax-funded subordinates that there is a
place for them in Congress well
something tells me Katie that that there
that I think those there are plenty of
the generates in Congress already so you
don't I don't think you needed to blaze
the way for them they were already good
so you're really just falling in line
with so many others you're just like
them those of you who know me personally
know that I'm a fighter and it's thanks
to countless other fighters who
supported me that we were able to stand
up for the idea that I blah blah blah
blah I can't even read anymore of that
it's just I wanted you to get a kid just
get it hear that because it's such a
bunch of self pitying nonsense she was
running around having sex parties with
with the subordinates who are paid with
tax money her behavior is wildly
unethical completely unacceptable and
and she is by no means a victim now I
said last week that you know the whole
revenge porn thing and releasing private
photos I'm not on board with that I I
think it's wrong and and whoever did it
probably did break the law and they
should be prosecuted for it so I'm I'm
an agreement there but as far as she's
good so we can talk about that
but as far as she's concerned all she
should be doing is apologizing she can
leave all of the self-righteous I'm a
fighter and I'll get through this what
are you fighting exactly Katie oh you're
fighting again because you were having
sex with your subordinates who are being
paid with tax money which is at a
minimum against the rules in Congress
probably also illegal and and that's why
this happened and of course there are
there you know we're hearing from plenty
of leftists who feel sorry for her and
are telling us that she's a victim how
horrible it is for her well I say now
for the 50th time that if she was a man
you know the nobody would feel sorry for
her nobody and she also would not be
able to get away with a resignation
statement like that they're they're
worse back during the heyday of the me2
movement when when men were being kicked
to the curb left and right there were
some guys who wouldn't when they
resigned from whatever position issued
statements sort of like that where they
made themselves out to be the victims
and they were ridiculed for it across
the media and for good reason most of
the time unless they really were
innocent yet we're not seeing the same
ridicule here we're seeing a lot of sort
of nodding heads and oh poor Katie poor
Katie okay now before we get two emails
let's talk briefly about Kanye West
first of all before we get to the album
this I think is the biggest headline
here's Kanye on something called big boy
TV I don't even know what that is but
here he is being interviewed about the
album but he starts getting into
politics a little bit and he starts
really laying down some facts and I
think this is great listen to this bro
we brainwashed out here bro come on man
this is a free man talking dip
Kress had his boat and democrats of food
stamps for years bro what are you
talking about guns in the 80s taking the
fathers out the home
Plan B lowering our boats making us our
board our children gosh in that kill I
think it's really hard to overstate the
significance of someone like Kanye West
saying what he just said now those of us
in the pro-life movement we've been
saying this for years the Democrats are
pushing abortion on to minority
populations and as a result minority
children are being exterminated by the
millions this is an in arguable fact
without abortion it is also an in
arguable fact that the black population
in terms of a percentage of the overall
population will be much much higher than
it is today
significantly higher we don't we can't
say exactly how much higher with any
precision but considering that in some
cities black children are more likely to
be aborted than born it's not hard to
see how the math would generally work
out if you didn't have abortion but the
problem the pro-life movement has ad is
how do we get this message to the people
who need to hear it the cities are all
run by Democrats they control the
messaging the media is run by Democrats
Hollywood the entertainment industry the
music industry all of it far left all of
it Democrat they're all minions of the
abortion industry they're all on the
same page with this so we need people
inside these structures to open their
eyes to the truth and start speaking it
so that they can reach the populations
that we have trouble reaching that's the
significance of what Kanye just did
there and and to an extent the
significance of what he's been doing for
a year now this to me I know some people
were you know made a big deal about it
when he came out in support of Donald
Trump which was great that he was
speaking his mind on that but to get
away from rather than just talking
politics to get into these get into the
trenches basically on these cultural
issues and speak out specifically about
something like this now that is enormous
ly significant and I would love to see
Kanye West perform at the March flight
I put that suggestion out there on
Twitter that's a serious suggestion who
knows and and he's got music that he
could perform now at the March for Life
namely the music that came out last week
Jesus is king as the album and you know
everyone's been talking about it's a big
sensation especially among Christians
now it's not very often that that
Christians it's conservative Christians
anyway will be big fans of a rap album
sort of a wrap up rap slash gospel album
it's just been looking on Facebook and
on Twitter and stuff there have been
people raving about a Kanye West album
who I never thought in a million years I
would see raving about a Kanye West
album and I think that's I think that's
great
not a complaint at all or a criticism I
think it's awesome so I think as for the
album itself I've listened to it maybe
three times now not hard to do because
the album is like 27 minutes long and
that is one complaint I have about it
many of the songs are way too short and
have sort of an unfinished feel to them
like the song Jesus is Lord at the end
of the album it starts and for the first
45 seconds it sounds like it's building
to being this great gospel track as the
music builds and builds a build and then
it just stops at 49 seconds and that's
it and it really feels like that was the
beginning of a song and then Kanye
forgot to do the rest of the song so we
just got the intro and and that was it
but there are also a couple of really
good song songs that feel complete the
one with Kenny G I forget the name of it
but that's probably my favorite it
reminds me of the old Kanye a little bit
has shades of college dropout to it that
same sort of vibe except with Jesus in
it in fact speaking of college dropout
Kanye's first album and I think I think
still to this day is best album and and
the best at one of the best albums of
the century I think in any genre but on
that album he had the song jesus walks
it which is one of my favorite songs and
so maybe that was my issue with this
with this one a little bit is that I
when I heard that Kanye was making a
Jesus album I thought it would be a
whole album of
jesus walks type songs and but none of
the songs on this album quite reach that
level and many of them don't even feel
like fully complete songs so that might
be affecting my ability to assess it
fairly given my expectations so here's
what I'll say as for the message of the
album I give that a 10 out of 10 I think
it's great and on on the message you
know the other thing that surprised me
with with these songs is this wasn't
just superfluous it wasn't a shallow
kind of Christian music talking points
which is what you get from a lot of
Christian music which is why I don't
like Christian contemporary Christian
music it's very very surface level
platitudes basically what it is that's
not he gets into some he gets in depth
and and talks I mean he gets into some
what I would call serious theology in a
way and also talks about the culture
[Music]
resisting sin you know obedience to
Christ repentance I me talks about this
on this album it so in that's and that's
again most contemporary Christian music
they're not getting anywhere near those
subjects so I was very impressed with
that
which is why message wise 10 out of 10
as for the music I give it a solid six
and a half to seven out of ten it could
be a nine out of ten I if he just goes
and I hope he goes back around and
finishes the album sometime maybe does a
remastered you know deluxe whatever
edition of it and in and finishes out
these songs I think it has the potential
to me it comes off like a rough draft of
a of a Christian sort of gospel rap
album if he finishes it which maybe he
will then I think it could go from music
wise pretty good to great okay let's go
to emails Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
Matt
all show at gmail.com this is from
Abigail says greetings future overlord
I'm going to disagree with you on
something so please forgive me and don't
do me and my entire family to a painful
death I don't know why you even bother
saying that if you're disagreeing with
me you know what the penalty is you have
accepted that and it's out of my hands I
work at an ice cream shop where I swing
the iPad around which gives an option
for a tip I'm a manager at most of the
time I'm by myself and do everything by
myself take their order make the ice
cream go outside clean up after children
adults or slobs my sister works in a
coffee shop where they take coffee very
seriously and she puts a lot of work
into that as well my point being just
because people don't physically wait on
tables doesn't mean they don't put a lot
of work into their service again please
don't execute me in my family first of
all the way that your groveling to me
like that
is actually exactly what I would expect
in my dictatorship so I do appreciate
that
as far as the thing about tips listen
it's I'm not yes I'm sure that what
you're doing your job you do work hard
but the tips it's not just about
rewarding people who work hard because
if tips are about rewarding people who
work hard in their jobs then we would
tip everybody right but we don't there
are people who do jobs that we view
where you'd think you would tip them
considering how hard they work
considering that what they're doing is
important for you but you can't do it
yourself
considering the service they provide
you'd think you tip them like for
example your plumber
nobody tips your plumber but if you're
gonna tip people who work hard they
provide a service we don't tip plumbers
though it's crazy to me that we tip cab
drivers uber drivers even the guy who
run who runs the you know the
complimentary hotel shuttle from the
airport to the hotel and back but we
don't tip the captain who pilots the
plane 30,000 feet in the air and keeps
you alive he's standing there when you
all whenever was shuffling out after the
plane lands he's standing there saying
goodbye to everyone I've never seen
anyone flipped slipped that guy of five
I think honestly we should
pilots they've really earned it but we
don't so it's not really a measure of
how hard you work some of it is just a
social convention where I can't really
figure out why we do tip certain people
and not others
but I guess my point is you know we know
that we tip waiters we tip delivery
drivers cab drivers okay if you're at a
hotel if it's a fancy hotel you tip
everybody so those are the conventions I
think that's kind of enough we don't
really need to add to it I think we do
enough tipping and that's my point if we
are gonna start adding and tipping more
people then in my opinion we're not
going to go to people work at coffee
shops or ice cream parlors which is no
offense to you any more than we're gonna
start tipping podcast hosts but if we're
gonna do that then why wouldn't we start
tipping electricians plumbers car
mechanics okay but let's as I said let's
just let's just stop we do enough of the
tipping we all spend enough money as it
is and that's it this is from Matthew
says dear Matt my name is Matt and I
live in Austin Texas I'm a greek
orthodox tradition but not the best
example i'm a huge fan of your show it's
a blessing to have someone like you and
conservative media or any media who's
not only brilliant and funny but also
willing to poke fun and be a bit
self-deprecating that's one reason I get
nauseated listening to Hannity and those
like him as it seems their primary
concern is with letting their listeners
know that their that they predicted and
said fill in the blank all along well in
fairness if I did predict something then
it happens I definitely let you know
about it and I will let you know so
that's one of the that's one of the joys
of doing a job like this I have two
questions one I'm a huge sports fan
especially college football but as long
as I look through Twitter and Facebook
and even the news part of me wonders if
perhaps I shouldn't focus on sports so
much and maybe try to focus on the
current state of affairs I completely
disagree with the quote religion is the
opiate of the masses but part of me has
started to wonder if sports has become
the opiate along with TV shows etc it
seems the only secular items that have
been remotely
working as the Dave Chappelle and
Bilborough specials even though I don't
agree with them on lots of things I have
tremendous respect for anyone who's
willing to speak out on the things we're
seeing and then number two will you come
to the University of Texas at Austin and
give a talk I can provide security as I
plan to start working out tomorrow well
on the second one yes I would be happy
to come on the first question I think
yeah we we can tend to over entertain
ourselves and I think generally in our
culture we are sort of entertaining
ourselves to death but in moderation I
don't see any problem with it and it
does it also kind of annoys so when
people are way too focused on on these
kinds of things and sports and
entertainment that becomes their entire
life unless it's what you do for a job
outside of that it becomes your entire
life I think that's a problem but on the
other side of it it also annoys me how
you know on Sunday you're watching
football and this happens to me Foot
Sunday comes I'm watching the games I
keep a track of it maybe I'll post a few
things to Twitter given my thoughts on
what's happening and without fail
they're always gonna people be people
who respond well all these things are
happening in the world and you know you
got Isis and Syria and everything and
you're talking about this
well yes those other things are
important but I don't have to spend 100%
of my time thinking about and talking
about all of the important things in the
world
nobody does that's not that's no way to
live it would be a strange way for a
human being to live I don't think any
human is capable of living like that so
there are going to be moments when
you're focused on things that aren't as
important and I think that that's one of
the joys of sports that's why I like
going to you know watch a football game
or something here you go to any stadium
to watch any sport I think one of the
joys is of it is that you're all there
you're focused on the game it's not very
important but it's a break from all the
madness that's going on on outside so
for it for those three or four hours
you're going to really care
about this game which doesn't matter but
that's the part of the attraction of it
and and there's nothing wrong with that
I think we need that we need those
breaks and we need to be able to focus
on things that aren't important so
there's a balance there and there's also
a balance and I think you have very
uninteresting and bland and boring
people who all they care about is pop
culture and watching TV and that's all
they can talk about and these are people
without personalities barely even human
anymore because their mind has been
replaced by a glowing screen so you've
got that but then on the other end of
the spectrum I think you have people who
are incapable of caring about or talking
about entertainment sports that sort of
thing I think those people also are very
bland and uninteresting and have given
up their personality so I think as human
beings it's sort of a balance so there
is that ok let's see one last I will
save this one for tomorrow actually Matt
well show it gmail.com is the email
address again for any emails you want to
spend we'll leave it there though thanks
everybody for watching Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer his Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena Matt
Walsh Oh is a daily wired production
copyright V Lee Weyer 2019 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle well tune in to the Ben
Shapiro show we will get a whole lot of
that and much more
see you there